how are you rich I'm doing great buddy I
am doing absolutely great banner you
hanging out with a [ __ ] yesterday uh
I was hanging out with Mitch Richmond he
says that he he knows he knows a lot
Michael but he didn't reveal he is still
my best friend
[Music]
yeah I know and when you were kind
enough to do this show all I was out of
the chair he was hanging with you for
two days it was great to have him here
in person and I told him I said you were
gonna have her Vaughn to talk about KD
and other subjects obviously a little
bit of the NFL but I'll give you the
floor here what did you think of when
you watched Durant go down on the floor
and grab his Achilles earth okay a great
number of emotions because you know we
got a look at it in look at the totality
of it all and as an athlete to know that
we have a commitment to one another you
know what I mean make sure that I will
do whatever I can and our job to get
back on the field or on the court to be
with the rest of our guys so I was like
wow this is incredible incredible story
he sees his guys are indeed and I heard
all the stuff about maybe Fela baby [ __ ]
but he said no this is what's most
important to me I want to be out here
I'm going to clay so you feel it a high
of that commitment cuz i watch emma
smith do it against the chinese you feel
of that commitment in that moment and
then the low of the injury which is very
very very hard to receive you know sir
and also risk what he went through as
you got hurt you can see the frustration
on his face and of course you know I I
just think the crowd was countable
feelings about what had happened you
know with clapping they were thinking
more championship then then I think
going at KD but it but it but it was
amicably Moses that I went through even
watching that I tweet about other
discusses the trauma and it's NBA it's
incredible and it has been incredible so
the notion that he should not have
played so many people have chimed in on
it from different parts of the sports
world
barclays obviously from win the NBA
we've seen Richard Sherman off you seen
Sherm who you know had an Achilles
injury significant Achilles injury
himself a couple years ago kind of on
the opposite and where do you land on
the subject of should he have played in
Game five and where he landed the same
place he landed on the spot it man I'm
going to play I want to play I mean you
know we love the game is one he had a
hell of an opportunity to make a hell of
a moment there and for those first 12
minutes putting up those the other
points he made that ball and now now
imagine if he had not got hurt and they
had to come back and won all these I
mean you understand what stratosphere
Kevin Durant would have gone in nobody
talks about the lure of this
stratosphere something that he's looking
to pushing past LeBron James pass the
Kawhi Leonard's and all of those things
he would have gone and that kind of
stratosphere you know so I'll and where
he'll and I I'm in that same situation
rich I'm doing the same thing he did did
you ever have a situation where give me
the the one where where you wanted to
get out you had to get out you needed to
get out and doctors in Dallas we're
telling you otherwise or you were
fearful that they were gonna tell you
otherwise earth well when I tore my
Achilles tendon in was 89 against the
49ers I I went back in the game you know
cuz I went out they taped that I'm good
I'm good to know like it was pretty
loose I said no I'm good I'm thank you
goodies we don't want to do anymore that
I should know I'm good I went back out
and played don't know what popped in our
pot later on now later on again but in
the moment in the heat of that moment
and you're looking at the guys that you
worked hard with and committed to all
offseason and putting all the work with
and in that situation you know mine
having second game of the season
a but that situation right there
it's a whole different thing because
they have a championship on the line
might happen the regular season of me
here's his he has a championship on the
line I would have definitely landed
right where he landed and and it's hard
even with a kowai kowai straight out
last but it was still no championship
right there sitting for help people are
downplaying that and I understand maybe
Berkeley downplays it maybe it doesn't
mean what it means to him
but to have that championship and have
opportunity to win another one I land
with Durant Michael Irvin here on the
Rich Eisen show what does he face in
terms of this you've suffered an
Achilles injury even more recently as I
pointed out different circumstances than
Game five of the NBA Finals
out there in Malibu and a flag football
game with Maria Menounos as you did I
watched you hurt your Achilles in that
game Irv
what-what-what what lies ahead for
Durant because I I strained my Achilles
and when I did my charity flag football
game years prior to that and and and I'm
gonna strain in it and and if I felt
like it was pretty close to what I see
Kevin Durant went through and I walked I
was able to walk off the field walk off
the field and they'll tell you when you
strain it sometimes don't you wait on
the scar tissue to feel the strain back
in and and you got a really massage it I
report for after I strained it I didn't
pass it I strained it I went the next
2-3 years hoping to pop it hoping a
pocket so I can go ahead and get it
takes all the way we haven't heard
anything yet I know he's went to New
York to get a to get a medical opinion
or for whatever reason it's just we
still don't know he walked off the court
he got up and won't happen it's not like
somebody shot me when I popped your time
shot me in the back Hill I fell down in
it there was no moving my foot I saw him
move the foot so III wanna I'm like I
don't know if that's a strain or is it a
pop a total pop cuz he was walking on it
and it's tough to
whoa will you pop that hamstring when
you pop that Achilles yeah I hear you I
mean he it did look like something did
it move within his calf I mean not to
get too graphic you know so we don't
know but and but I still wanted you on
nonetheless to give you your couple
cents on this subject well I do have you
let's talk a little NFL but before we
get to that another subject du jour of
the day is the amount Michael Irvin of
celebrating the US Women's National Team
did in France at the 13-nothing
beatdown of the Thai national team I'd
love to give you the T is there such a
thing as too much celebrating I don't
know if you saw any of it if you thought
it was too much well what you live over
it's a rest on this here now here's what
I say when I see all of that to now
there's so much there's so much going on
in just the naked eye seeds you know
because those women they're in a battle
right and they're in a battle I'm
talking about all the politics or
whatever for equal rights and all of
this stuff and everything and Aben
balance so you know each moment they
make each moment they make out there
they're going to make it dawn they're
making a moment we are here it's what
we've been talking about this is what
we're doing
I have no issue with a wet so ever it's
always you to tell people if you don't
like me doing my first down being all do
people get the first down to beat you
you be mr. nice guy not the little stuff
where everybody gives the participation
participation trophy I'm going to beat
you down and I want you to know I beat
you down because that's what makes me
crave yes
that's just the reality I have issues
with whatsoever yeah I'm
Megan Rapinoe said today and she's been
one that really has been in the
spotlight because she scored her 45th
international goal right and it made the
game either ate nothing 9 nothing at the
time and she celebrated as if it was her
first she today said that if they're
guilty of the crime of joy she's fine
with that is basically what she said
Michael yeah turn disappear she sounds
very smart very intelligent just the way
she delivers that line right there
people down your mouth to say that to
really body so for her to say that
that's collected in Greece people
applause well I mean just to take the
quick flip side here I mean that you're
showing up an opponent you know when it
you soccer might see this and see
somebody celebrating a ninth goal a
tenth goal at some point you do you do
let the up on the gas because the game
is over and the celebrations aren't that
necessary you so what do you say to
something like that or with a different
level this is the best of the best and I
told Tyler in the competition they're
certainly not one of the top teams but
this is the best versus the best right
here and you got to do what you have to
do to bring the best out of you because
you're playing a little league stuff
because you know everybody wants to
participate everybody wants to be nice
we don't make anybody feel bad you know
but at this level things change and we
have to differentiate between them
because if you don't do what you need to
do your best you know what in like in
Italy you get cut you know so I'm not
going to lose what I worked so hard for
because somebody says I'm not like even
look you know I understand
at one level but at another it changes
in at that level things change a couple
more minutes left with my Hall of Fame
friend Michael Irvin you're at the star
right now are you at this Dallas star
right I am glad to practice right now I
kind of fact they just stepped out the
door because they they get to play music
and practice nowadays you know we didn't
get that stuff Jimmy would have gone
crazy
you know ta Jimmy wouldn't alone music
and practice the day off - Sharlee wit
and all of those guys just catching up
with how long's in this field and what
they see I tell you this rich I walk in
the building overhearing this understand
being in the building they've been
practicing
Sweetback everybody in this building is
Randi raving about Randall cause I been
interesting to see just what he does for
the Dallas Cowboys issue I mean
everybody I talked to rainy raving about
Randall Cobb and I knew it remember we
did that show free agency show there
Marvin who is that's the first thing he
was talked about a man that's one of the
guys I would have gone after if I was
still in that position if I was still
here coach he said he's one of the best
he's always blocked it and we talked
about it I told him I said we talked
about this before you guys picked them
up and I mean that's all they're talking
about so it'd be interesting to see how
they played so when you sat in this
chair for me in first week of May you
had Jerry Jones on and he flat-out
reiterated in perfect plain English that
they are committed to Jack Prescott and
yet Carson Wentz is the one who was
signed earlier than expected and they
signed him to a contract that gives him
an annual salary of eight figures it
starts with a three why hasn't anything
happened with the Dallas Cowboys yet Irv
it's only gonna get more expensive if
they wait
hey I mean you see the same thing you
know we're seeing the same thing it's
going to get more and more expensive and
that's why I don't understand what
people get into this thing about why how
can you pay him that kind of money and
all of that stuff is absolutely he's
worth absolutely all that money in the
price is just going to go up it's not
going down
I guarantee you why it isn't done it's
more on that side it is Oh Cheers I get
it done yesterday like you know people
argued about some ways you were 30 if
you were 30 now at a minimum he's worth
30 to a year because that's what cause
I'll tell you this Irv I mean if I want
dockside and Jerry Saud keeps coming
back with an annual eight figures salary
that starts with a - I'm sitting there
saying where's the three yeah of course
I'm gonna be waiting I mean certainly
you know golf's around the corner and I
mean he he took the team to Los Angeles
for round two I mean this is something
that other quarterbacks once doesn't
even played a playoff game I mean let's
be honest here so is he worth the money
or not rich let me let me give it this
way and I said somebody last week the
one thing that people don't talk enough
about and what makes New England
Patriots the great great as they are
it's the hottest solar we that's what
Chris Carr is for this team that alone
is worth 20 million dollars a yard will
kill with anybody you talk if you got
the quarterback being the leader the
heart is 15 play football too
that's the market that's where do you
that's where it is Wow
so before I let you go did you hear
patch rumors say they're gonna play the
best player at the quarterback position
this year but he loves the starter
daniel Jones is getting set to play I
like I still don't understand it I mean
it's it's Eli's gig writer yeah when you
hear that when you hear that you know I
gotta give you every chance every chance
to to do what he does but okay now
everybody I'm hearing people talking I
thought that more daniel Jones will
great and he said people started over
with okay we were wrong on here on this
situation and he gets outed he does
things it's going to be a hard turn
it'll be a hard turn tell people you
know people are they always say I I
remember great Tom Landry when I came
here I got drafted by him and everybody
while we were losing everybody was
saying it made his time to make a change
maybe it's time to make the change and
then when Jerry bought the team and
actually made a change
everybody wanted get rid of Jerry wait a
minute you can't change big that's a
wait a minute
you guys seeing this everything I read
we're saying it and now that happens you
get upset so people were told by the
side of Paul from Eli well when it's
time you get the best mass of it and
that's going to be a hard decision if
that kid keeps progressing like I'm here
he's progressing and and Eli comes out
and does will jump out to the early part
of the season all right last one for you
see the Raiders here on Hard Knocks sir
did you see that
yeah yeah I love I love he was brother
with Jay Riecke publicly said there's
another Gruden go follow go follow him
and
and I mean how I mean how how much how
much your Antonio Brown you think we're
dissing on that show what do you think
we're going to see all of the Antonio
Brown this board at the interesting - I
guarantee you and Tony around and get
the most out of it - now really the
social media man numbers up some more
you know saying so he'll get the most
out of that he'll have fun yeah I think
it'll be a very interesting just seeing
the inner workings of it now you know I
think the tough part of it on I love
watching hard-nosed it's always watching
would like I get released yeah I mean
I'm shooting all of it but don't go in
their room let that go leave me
something sacred okay going down
confessional this is my confessional go
in there I deal with that part five
himself we know what happened in that
we've seen enough of that but but but
yeah I love the show and I think John
the Raiders that's going to be an
incredible incredible
yeah May out - and and I mean in terms
of mature audiences shows on HBO Game of
Thrones and the soprano is the wire
where would a Hard Knocks of your Dallas
Cowboys when you played ranked Michael
[Laughter]
so way up there is basically what you're
saying you know what I think well well
we're doing this show right and we
happen to catch Tom Coughlin's coming in
- again that's right you always call me
Danny looks like
my lawn
alright or take care of yourself have a
good time there at the star blows what
you're doing for the network there we'll
see I'll see you this weekend all right
I'll see this weekend birthday party yes
birthday party is that right I mean I
need to check the evite list hold on a
second you gotta see me that's Michael
Irvin 88 on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app